[Musique]
vous pensez à la vengeance ou et robert
ou et ont défini une ligne à cela
déchire l'âme dit moins pourrait-on
frère mais ça peut aussi être une arme
je ne fuirai plus j'en ai assez de me
cacher le pouvoir sait prendre des
décisions et quelles que soient vos
choix
je serai à vos côtés mon époux
nous devons réunir les casses robert
bruce état hors la loi quiconque
l'hébergera lui ou ses soldats
sera exécuté sur le champ le peuple a
soif de justice
je sers bien bruce rejoignez nous pour
libérer nos terres
[Applaudissements]
j'ai cinquante hommes pour combattre
l'armée la plus puissante du monde
voilà ce que nous allons faire
nous reprendrons nos terres château car
château
battez vous pour dieu
pour le pays
[Musique]
pour la famille
de ma porte
tant que vous vous battez